yes good to start yeah [ __ ] yeah no it's
people here it's got the great Jim
Breuer the favorite comics the goat but
also I'm about to kick off of a world
tour or at least in North America tour I
like when they say North America me to
North America Jim Breuer this is to
called the tour living let laughs living
that laugh I'm not doing all of America
I'm too busy I can only do North America
your inaudible problem honey date you
can you bring it up Joe how many dates
do you have Jim I want to say like 30 28
636 yeah a lot dude how about that
picture right there you just like what
yeah what hairs all good that's me
coming out of a blonde that's coming out
of a putt look that's you is that you
just saying just shook your hair out and
you're just like why your day somebody
said to you hey Jim you you're number
one anyway I left
hey Jim you never won you went huh or is
that a man you forgot to put your pants
on yeah you pants are off hey Jim Jim
you got a dick on you why yeah then
you're going yeah hey yeah hey look have
you're going yeah you look hidden look
pleasantly surprised I like I like the
to the left in the middle that's me
going I might get a roll somewhere
you're sure that you're great I look
sexy tonight I might you know exactly
it's time for me to start being looked
at as something a little different than
funny Yeah right there and if I'm
casting a therapist right there who's
really listening to me that's the guy
right there right I think right before
he says to me hey listen I've been doing
this a long time and kill yourself
if you don't move your mouth you guys
kill yourself I look like I really care
about what you're saying yep
but inside you're going on okay did they
show you the picture with yeah that's
brillo
oh I clearly said yeah absolutely think
about you Jemma said you're super into
aesthetics the one thing about you is
your real detail-oriented about and
controlling about your image can we
light up the top please give me more
light in my forehead perfect that's the
shot let's go with it it's kids go with
that not lost a stitch your hair at 52
and I've lost a lot of mine and and
you're you're not great dude look a tiny
tiny tiny bit is starting to show up on
this color no you don't let it go no no
do you still smoke a lot of weed no I
stopped for a long time that's what I
heard
long long time why did you stop a lot of
things eh I was addicted to it mm-hmm
you can't go to duty can you can when
you're planning your day around it
mm-hmm then and redic to the feeling of
being hi oh god yeah it was such a but I
also would get crazy paranoid uh while
you were high yeah crazy pair you're
like everything in the house has to be
turned unplugged cuz they're listening
to me it was all van and there and there
tapping in the thoughts cuz my thoughts
are so powerful they can change the
world kinda we did the right people I
was gonna say that was strange why we do
you mean acid never this was pure weed
that's not a day did you do it when you
were on Saturday Night Live like gonna
come up in comedy all those years uh
yeah yeah I've been affected it was um
it's not a blow involved there's no blow
in our cast no it was all weed
oh maybe boozing weed and booze goes
along with the creativity right I mean
weed a lot of people do it like well I
started or there's weed all I start
doing numb myself cuz y-you weren't
happy oh it's frustrating so first it's
a tough frustrating invite it was inside
live the environment is really it's a
pressure cooker right like some people
love it and some people hate it
I
loved it is just it's not the easiest
for a comedian because you're up you're
up working on weather monkey or [ __ ]
is a funnier word you're carving out
every sketch right you're fighting for
your characters you're fighting free
characters you're you're working on
things on stage you know it works on
stage yeah and then you come back and
you have 40 you're competing with 14
people trying to write to get their
thing on with 10 15 cast members trying
to get their thing on go to his cast Jen
I'm sorry live but it was one of the
greatest times ever had my whole life
and then when when something like goat
boy goes freaking I mean just not
sickest thing ever
where were you a little like because
they were using a lot more we kind of
come on let's do something else or did
you love it
no to be honest with you I hate
repetition that's right absolutely yeah
not so but wenton once in a while
Lorne would go Jim we could really use
the goat this week but dude can I be
honest with you so that was my second
year of MADtv we come back we were like
we're gonna beat SNL right right and it
was that one foot it was the so so you
guys opened it was the first time you
ever did go poi and it was when Tom
Hanks Tom Hanks bro that was the first
and I say as somebody we were all set
around as a cast to watch you guys and
when he marries here that I'm working
with Tim Meadows right now by the way I
love doing school with him that's a
Mongolian oh I'm sure yeah I'm so so
dude I'm telling you right now Jim we
were all singing around here we were
ready for the next season and you guys
caught on it was one of the greatest
episodes do you feel so bad that episode
that Oakley the way you open this run
the greatest episodes ever and all of us
kind of hung our heads when I saw Gopal
what mary share the great mary share of
growling they started laughing so hard
we were laughing so [ __ ] are so
outrageous mad and you were you're
drinking from the oh my god and we were
like what we're done we're [ __ ] we're
never gonna compete with these guys
they're just too good well two things
one is you're not gonna find a goalie
sketch mmm with Tom Hanks no no I'm say
there's good at all the go boys are
missing why I have no clue the
she'll sketches of goat boy with the Tom
Hanks and the Pamela Anderson and all
that I don't know why Tom was incredible
every single one of them is just missing
they're gone
well you can't go on SNL site you can't
go on NBC site why is that I live
release them I have them zero clue I
think it's the only character that's
terrible
where it's nowhere such so cuz my kids
were trying to look for this they
haven't seen it and they were like you
were to Tom Hanks so I asked oh thing
like what you it was such an imam hanks
laughed so he he was laughing he laughed
so hard but it wasn't supposed to be
that by the way I was actually
aggravated with the sketch turned into
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know here's I pitched it as a guy
with Tourette's that's like a [ __ ] did
I when I want to do a guy Tourette's
but his Tourette's is a goat noise and
originally this is true from Tourette's
to goat boy right so check this out so I
said he when he's nervous around women
and when he sings it comes out so if he
likes his chick him I came and I think
you did you beautiful and so there's no
rhyme or reason why he had this and that
led to I'm singing I and the first so
start spread in the and then it didn't
everyone looked at me nuts really in the
room that he'll love it they thought I
was psychotic
about your justice my life about a year
later they tried it as boy sings 80
songs and it was only a two minute thing
so just me going you can dance and you
want to your friends behind and shout
shout let it all so ended the first
season was on second season Tom Hanks is
on and the guy that DNA with me goes I
swear to god he goes goes all right you
know the go thing all right what if the
government had a secret weapon but it
but it failed so now they're stuck with
this poor half-goat thing and so but he
loves singing songs so he only sings 80
songs cuz that's his program do and then
E and then vh1 gives them a show it's
called go boy hey remember the 80s but
hosted by go boys and well I poet white
I'm all over it I said no like yeah
we're gonna put you in a hole and little
did we know 20 years later we're
laughing when you're drinking from one
point they cut away at Thomas we all
lost again one way to come up with Tom
Hanks and you're like yeah drinking oh I
think from an utter or something I guess
Hanks one did Tom Hanks go boy I saw
something you can figure out the
conspiracy why all the dope boys are
missing
honestly explained your your cast was
amazing Jim yeah I mean yet one of the
molly was a powerhouse sherry Ocala has
a powerhouse Will Ferrell's beyond
superstar yeah Tracy Morgan belly laugh
and fun who's Harold Hamm and oh my god
III saw Darrell the other night at the
comic store oh good for ya good
I miss him yeah do you stay connected
with everyone or not really really you
know who does though you like you
everyone's so busy it's like that you
don't like them but it's like when
you're not in the same Lane like when
you're not driving
for the same girl and work like yet
family it's like it when I call him and
I left the world after this was done I
was done with Hollywood done with the
rats I just was done why I was exhausted
why we end up
it was Lena Jim the show the the lead-up
to Senate live was so exhausting just
mentally I already had it I just had it
and it takes the fun I had it took a lot
of fun it took the event I had vengeance
towards you know chip of Hollywood and
Jay I had a major chip I was older and
I'm not a chip on my shoulder you know
outside I live for how long three years
and then you get done white why do you
have a chip on your shoulder with the
chip so it was delete this is the long
lead up so when I first when I start
doing stand-up was in high school but
then when I got serious was 1989 it was
on and off and then 1918 I know what
this is what I'm doing and how old were
you 18 18 no no 89 85 so like 21 21
years old I go this is what I'm doing
forever okay and I started and I was
living in Florida so I'm touring rounds
comedian and then worked my way to a
middle act 30 minutes and then and then
I knew it was time doing a road and then
I knew it's time to go to New York LA
back to New York where I'm from and I
got in TV pretty quick I got a first I
was on a show called the uptown comedy
club which was filmed in Harlem which is
where me and Tracy Morgan first oh wow
Tracy Morgan when I met him on the
uptown comedy club he would always show
up with those hats almost like the way
Spanky wore and Lou Rascals yeah but it
had a little propeller on top and he
would come in for hours we'd get nothing
done cuz he would just come in and rant
for an hour I was on the subway no son
my man shoot she was wrong mama mama had
this bottlenecks huh and she was she was
raging waves good
no no homeless man subjected my and he
would cause he's watch him he was so
that's wonderfully odd and he would and
he would put in these crazy details that
was they would paint the picture he was
so funny so after that show then me and
Chappelle were up for uh baked knows
before half baked mean him I had a huge
development deal with NBC he had a huge
deal with HBO Dave and at the last
second we got pulled from our deals so
we came together beyond this disney show
called buddies interesting and we were
on the cover of TV Guide the commercials
on it was a spinoff of home improvement
so we went on a home improvement and
then the second episode while my
commercials that flew my best friend's
out for the premiere and I got fired
that's how it works I'm ill the second
episode because however no business
never the most frustrating thing was and
never they don't tell you
yeah like did I suck did I know I did
whatever the reason was yeah so it's
gladder he took his taken away so from
there that makes you upset oh no no no
so from there I mean it's devastating
for sure business though and its
business and then you're frustrated
because before that I was with the with
um I wanna say his name was Pollak he he
was Will Smith's producer for that show
Fresh Prince of bel-air and signed this
deal with NBC so they can develop heat
they I met Will Smith and like this is
gonna be great so to get pulled from
that to break that contract so we can
guarantee go on the air with Dave
Chappelle Chappelle was pulled from HBO
he was banned from HBO Jesus there was a
big lawsuit yeah why he banned I can't
remember because he because they deal -
deal he had the original Chris Rock deal
which was two one-hour specials in his
own talk show and he was only 20 21 so
then that and I get fired from that for
what whatever mmm saw whatever the
reason okay
days later Fox says are upset that
you've got can you audition for us today
and I auditioned it was Herman's head or
something whatever shows that she and I
got it
I like that and I got it yeah I got the
show and Disney at the times did you not
allowed to do it because we don't have a
contract with Fox and you're still with
us Jesus
so here now I'm trapped so I get fired
and now I can't even not getting even
get work some rage against machine and
then that goes and then they say it's
gonna be a pickup and then it doesn't
get picked up and then then I got clerks
and then from clerks they fired Chris
Schmitt they couldn't be part of the
project and then the we picked it up and
then they didn't pick it up and they
fire the the star and it was just a big
she was nuts and then Senate life came
we how many did you audition just once
or did you don't know I was the last
guys as the last guy hired so I time so
you go through six riously right then
you you test you go in you come back you
do it for producers you [ __ ] how made
you do Jim now here's what I did I
auditioned and I didn't want to audition
I said oh no no I I know Jay I know some
people that are on there and they are it
made them ugly well you like change
their made them ugly people like being
president yeah and so uh and so with
that I auditioned and the next day in
the newspaper it said senator lives
searching for our all-new cast nation
one of those already written off
comedian Jim Breuer who had two sitcoms
go bust on him and a man I want know
knows who I was you hmm why would you
write that in a newspaper what what whoa
it was a my hey everyone's like man I
can't believe they wrote that and
Wynonna and then they asked me to go
back like why am I gonna go back they
clearly already wrote in the paper yeah
and then I went back and then they met
with me and
that was awkward and then what did you
do in your audition did you do that and
remember I am some people do like
multiple characters and sometimes not do
one yeah you don't even have five
characters I know if MADtv was like five
care I wasn't good at the characters
I really wasn't I'd not for the audition
oh that was so eventually I was the last
guy hired and when you stoked when you
got found out the news no I was
exhausted
oh it's completely exhausted really yeah
I'd even know if I really had here's the
whole process you were exhausted yeah
and then right before I got it there was
uh I remember meeting and I was told you
knows a lot of people here that are not
fans you being on the show and there's a
lot pulling for you
so thank you Thank You Liz that's true
that night and that's now correct me
wrong you can be fired any minute yeah
rightly so do you never have job
security you're never that if you don't
start doing more characters but that's
why they put out monsters yeah that the
pressure like the same would say it same
with sports yeah right score zero point
hunter crimes fights you don't have a
job percent right so so it's it creates
it it creates a tempo in your own in
your body in your mind though even when
you get the job you're never relaxed are
you never relaxed and then so once I got
it though I loved the environment it was
frustrating but so worth it when you hit
that home run yeah and then in houses
you know it's frustrating you this
writers pain your ass and this guy
doesn't like you it's just and then how
did you know it was time to leave when
you left there you had a big chip in
show just because then I was exhausted
there was the guys that pushed me to be
on left the leather towards the end of
the second season I was on and my hand
of God their words to mirror like Jim
you're we quit this guy Fred wolf and
Steve corn they quit and they said uh
good luck man because they're coming at
you who's coming at me their kid
it he's coming at you I won't say who
but um and then I realized that last
year like oh my god people are oh my god
somebody like Machiavellian right and
you never expected you're like what and
then then it's so that battle and the
the stories go on and on and I'm so um
passed them a home and healed from it
all but Abed but I've had fresh you've
gotten fired from that show yeah and
after five six years and like it's six
years right and there's nobody tells you
you just hear from your agent that your
or your thumb the press well I actually
got to talk to Lauren oh you did which
is incredible did they let you go or you
decided to leave here's exactly how it
went down this is with Lauren the whole
thing yes at the end of the third season
they I got a call from an NBC executive
and he said Jim what happened this year
what are you talking about he said
so-and-so and so-and-so are doing
everything they can to get you fired
what not I knew exactly he was talking
to no I can't
is it cast members or writers writers oh
that's terrible
and so I went whoa what and so I go I
don't know he's like man I'm just
telling you this is what so I called
each one mm-hmm one game one wouldn't
take my call one did and he told he was
like oh no boo boo the Hollywood talk a
play pal you're my you're my guy
actually we're trying to get someone
else fired
he goes no not you I don't know I had an
an NBC executive said I can get fired
for telling you this
yeah but this is I mean this is my kids
lives it's a true story
so I knew this other guy was a problem
so I I told I went to my refs and what I
don't want to be on that show anymore if
he's the main person it's not where it's
not worth my health and my it's just not
worth it am I gonna lose out on a great
show and all that no work environment is
worth that in my in my in my mind and so
Lauren talked to me and he said Lauren
he said Jim why don't you once you once
you have dinner with the guy I said I'll
try and that's right and it wasn't
working out and then and then Lauren and
I asked to be released and Lauren said
Jim if you ever need anything call me
I'm your guy and you're too nice for
this business you're just too nice for
this but Jesus and that's it that's what
the great Lauren Michael said to me and
I've always always had the highest
respect for him yeah yeah yeah hey you
know some people whatever he does he
does I mean well you can say whatever
you want that guy is a genius jeez and
he's if I he's really great comedic
figures of the 20th century and still
the greatest in some ways as far as a
facilitator producer understanding what
works how to make great people he takes
he could creates greatness out of you
and he also creates that environment
where you either sinkers well well that
daddy I don't know if you had the
audition of the audition like I've the
audition process I've heard from people
I gave me polar and taran killam and I
mean it's the audition process is like
America's great like the Navy SEAL I had
a part of Mike Moore and I told him
because I had the key tomorrow I went to
win a March show Lauren asked me he
pulled me in the room you know I said
Lauren wants to talk to you okay and I
sat down and Lauren asked me about two
different people that he wanted to hire
one was Marc Maron and he said Jim what
do you think of Marc Maron and my exact
words were now this was then I said well
a lot of people don't like him and I
said I'm I don't like him either however
if you're talking about hiring him for
the update desk
I think he'd be he'd be one of the best
I go but as
a person I can't stand them he's just
difficult back then right he's a dick
yeah that's what everything was a long
thing about a being yeah he was the big
is he admits it though and that's the he
minute when I shown we talked about it
yeah I could he was very insecure back
then like that's what I always got yeah
yeah and and why that would drive people
like me nuts cuz I'm always a you're an
open book I'm all been bugging on the
awful one one for all
I mean me too you beat me out you beat
me out you [ __ ] this on stage once
I'm doing killing at the comic strip and
Jim Jim you're sensitive you're like me
yes super senses well I mean because
you're you're the most common so but Jim
is Jim and Jim is the world's a
playground he's doing stand-up it's a
it's in New York City he's crushing at
the cottage I mean crushing and there's
a [ __ ] dude that was my home yeah
there's a dude and he's just sitting
there like that
nothing I'm I was watching his face he's
crawling pissed he's just cry like this
his mouth his openings like this like
he's about to go [ __ ] you literally
right you know the face before you right
before you go [ __ ] you like yeah like
hey [ __ ] you but not what daddy's doing
that
so finally Jim goes hey I got to stop
for a second is there a problem no way
and the guy goes you should say
something funny
oh so Jim says water remember that Jim
goes but they're all laughing every I
remember you did this for your fingers
but everybody's laughing so he goes yeah
like that he goes okay keep going
[ __ ] finally another three minutes
you're still not laughing I just don't
get this cuz you just look at me like
you're really pissed did I do something
to you and the guy goes I don't know you
should say something funny
Wow but he's a dick because Jim's
looking at him and you said something
about a shirt and he had like hair he's
a guy who took his driving way too
seriously
got a guy who wears [ __ ] those those
those moccasins what yeah yeah yeah Mary
had long hair an open shirt just a [ __ ]
head
and with a good chain and [ __ ] [ __ ] head
supreme and finally
finally you go but I want you to like me
my gosh they got laughing laughing dying
but this is the best because I want you
like this yeah he's like he now he shuts
up he's just like looking at you like
that you're still looking at me like
that you're still looking you come to a
comedy story it's amazing you and he
goes well I don't think you're funny and
then you go oh no buddy well now I'm
gonna have to go home and you've got up
on the stool and you rapped you took the
cord and he just hangs on you're dying
and you died I we we were laughing so
[ __ ] our dose of crazy sing everything
I go do there's a finding of you when
you were like put a dick he was such a
dick that's so mad at you I remember the
hawk hung yourself and it was the
greatest bit I've ever seen in my life
that guy probably felt like such a tool
thing he was a tool anyway so of course
he did the mock hanging tomorrow yeah
hung yourself as the greatest thing I've
ever seen on this - I remember doing
nothing to do and you were going my god
and you kept making these from
high-pitched noises Wow I bet I used to
love playing there Oh what are you
talking about now with your stand-up
like you feel like you have to if you
ever do colleges you have you know
world's very [ __ ] platino who does
really do come now don't usually be the
thing Leo I think Chris Chris does I
don't do colleges I do theatres and I do
uh I don't know what the last three
years I do a lot of improv lotta
off-the-cuff a lot of family a lot of
where I'm at in life getting up around
New York is that New York New Jersey or
no we stay together have you been
getting up a ton around there at the
club
I'll get around any club I know I
shouldn't say I'm the worst one thing
that helps is I have a have a residency
on Long Island it's just it's a place
called the Paramount it's a great
theater and I've been playing there 18
months in a row and knowing that I had
to change non-stop to get people to keep
coming out oh you do a show there once a
month
Wow right and that that stressed me out
because people like a lot of you ER and
friends or is no it's always it's always
just me
Wow do you have openers or I do have an
opener telling that sing out every time
sold it out yeah which in my drawers I'm
not gonna lie to you I'd listen I'd love
to go it is great I'm I never get the
guy always go there's people out there
like yeah dude was sold out sold out
yeah just eleven don't you people sold
out what you're funny yeah so that again
and it's that really changed yes
it gave me so most so much confidence to
go out and and talk about what's on my
mind without taking news in politics I
never touch the news of politics and
just real-life scenarios where there's
death going on my family so my wife
being sick whatever the scenario is I
just go out so what am I talking about
whatever's going on in my life mm-hmm
and I try to relate it to everyone
that's going on and before you were
doing that residency where you you took
time off from stand-up no I think you
have non-stop yeah non-stop that's the
way we do it is always you get an offer
you go yeah I'll do that
okay you got another offer okay so you
know Arizona to Florida and would comics
do I don't know we free here we just
take offers and then we try to string
them together until you become a
Sebastian or Kevin Hart yeah and then
you go hey we're doing a tour because
now they're there in the rock star mode
the other arenas they're Riina's and so
now this is the first time I think
Metallica tour helped tremendously I
think you want
I bring that up Jen
I am sees a big difference saying I am
seed I was there opening him I don't
like say out in the open ur cuz it
wasn't that I opened in time to word
you're like the host yes
so no where's the Metallica so when you
got in their immediate coats when you
showed up in the Metallica show I had
old pictures of Metallica on stage okay
so as you're walking in you're seeing
old metallic pictures then I had a DJ go
up from 7 you can bring a birdie video
yeah
or 7:00 to 7:30 I had a DJ go up and he
took all requests which I programmed he
first came to a solution Pluto no no
this is Metallica fans we all got kids
is to play for Van Halen ac/dc scorpions
Judas Priest that's what you play then I
would go up 7:30 to about 8 8 10 the
crowd work story in that group go in the
audience be so difficult in a theater
and around it's not an old-school iclal
a lot of old-school comics used to open
up for big musicians so it's it's
nothing you know it's back in the day
with it yeah and it was and it was it
was in the round which was pretty
intense so there's you gotta constantly
people around you go to the the 1 819
yeah I go to that one I'm afraid we need
are you showing sing-along oh this was a
muscle okay if we even hit this okay if
you want a stake in the best fight card
on the 2019 calendar my friends I don't
know if it's the best but it's damn good
you gotta go to my bookie DC is fighting
steep a in the rematch you got Nate Diaz
is back for the first time since done 16
us a keys to 41 is stacked in my book is
the place to put the money baby
my bookie has better bonuses and more
MMA odds in any other sports book period
that's why I use them tell us see some
bad dudes there's football season nobody
does game day better than my bookie this
year they're hosting the first online
handicapping super contest first place
is Darren
to win $100,000 and only costs $100 to
enter
pick five NFL games against the spread
every week climb the leaderboard and
score your share of the huge cash prizes
with the only reason we recommend them
is because we use them they pay you play
they pay every time and actually
especially for the big UFC's this UFC 41
I will be posting my pics on my
Instagram story and using my bookie so
check that out so you can make some
money with a little bit of help of my
pics on my IG story and krisily and I
are doing some head-to-head competition
on my bookie you can bet on which of us
can fit more marshmallows in our mouth
he's got a big mouth that's gonna be
times I can't wait guys who can undress
the fastest sure I am the same outfit
foaming at the mouth to figure out he's
giving ok get the loudest laugh at the
Comedy Store or at the comedy show and
who can hold a note longer and who can
whip milk into cream faster yeah so
there's some physical stuff there's a
vocal stuff there's some comedy stuff
that's really cool man now up to $1,000
first deposit bonus double your first
deposit all right use promo code fighter
to activate this offer visit my bookie
online today that's my B oh ok ie and
don't forget to use the promo code
fighter good luck this weekend you'll
see 241 Bret and I want my skin to look
vital I wanted to look young I wanted to
look shiny I wanted not to crack what do
I do
steroids besides that though Brennan if
I can't afford steroids what would I do
do you mean like gnats like naturally I
want natural I want to look real good
what do you think what do you will tell
me your goals and then oh ok look bottom
line is I want total optominute II and I
know that's not a word but I want my
body to be balanced strong I want it to
go forever and be healthy I want to be
healthy I want to count idea I want a
vibrate bro
I want to glow I want to look pregnant
but not be pregnant you know what I'm
saying
go Brian are you a 20-something year old
pregnant gal cuz your skin you're
glowing is it glow is busting it's
busting in a good way in a good way
what do i do Brent take take take on it
supplements and bust them all over your
face
is that right yeah that supplements I'm
not gonna bust some on my face I'll bust
you no no that's the that's the arm that
the kids use yeah but I that's it bust
them on your that's the term that they
use in pornography no I'm gonna bust
them in my mouth yes that's also kind of
bust them in your gut with some water
with some water
look man dude if I want to go if I if I
if I want to up my workouts and go extra
hard
I go shroom tech immune try that stuff
do those things I take yeah well
shroom tech immune if you're a keto kid
they got everything to support that so
you can lose weight I'll be down at 2:35
by October we'll see probably already
shot city
thanks to on it they got total keto
daily they got glutamine electrolytes
they got shroom tech as be said they got
everything go to audit comm slash
fighter to receive tempers off the whole
Dan
dang dang they got content they got tea
too thick audit calm / I got [ __ ] yeah
coffee so get some [ __ ] yeah coffee yeah
bust in your mouth yeah do you know what
there are bracelets that can track your
fitness
there are bracelets that can track your
sleep they're bracelets that can track
your heartbeat
there's bracelets they can track your
recovery rate but from what I've
researched from what I've seen and I
know you take your fitness seriously but
on your wrist almost always is the whoop
bracelet the whoop 3.0 by the way that
gives you analytics more with your sleep
your recovery how much your turn your
performance how many calories you're
burning
I mean it's track in your heart rate
24/7 it doesn't matter second second
what's your sleep do you know what kind
of sleep you're kidding no weird the
whoop you're gonna find out what kind of
sleep good sleep REM all that stuff
smell and coach so it gives your
training level recommendations based on
your body's recovery to take the
guesswork out of how hard to push
yourself for optimal training it does
everything you need to be at your best
tracks your calories - how many how many
burn everything at the highest level
it's a little small band it's easy
they'll it last five days although I
don't charge mine every fight didn't
last long again you run with ice cream
with it I've run with it water press
play all day with it it's free if you
have sex with it everything right dude
name something I'm doing ha it is go to
whoop calm that's WH Oh Oh Pete calm use
the code fighter at checkout and save
$30 to optimize the way you train get
something right now that's won't wh Oh
Oh Pete calm promo code fighter for $30
off your membership whoop is a
performance tool to get your mind right
and your body better this is great
so I already create bits and some of
them were game shows I bring by bring
Metallica fans on now here's the thing
you see the audience Lars Ulrich told me
goes listen to muscle he goes the reason
why we hired you is because is Lars fan
clearly he said identical there's a
reason why we hired you it goes you know
how to read an audience you've been
around a long time
seen you cuz you know Metallica's fans
you know the band because your
professional create a show because but
the most important thing is you don't
have to be funny cuz get a DJ get you
whatever you need tell me I said well I
tell you this I'm gonna need screens oh
I need screens any good I said what
about a live Cameron he goes like this
do like talking to a king he goes hold
on a second and he lifts up his phone he
gives me the whole time
hey hey I've got Jim Breuer here what's
how do we get screens at a live camera
can we do that is that in the budget
okay and then he goes don't be
disappointed he goes
we always hire bands to open first
nobody comes to see the band's because
this is why we're trying this yeah and
he goes it's a bummer for the band's
it's a bummer for us he goes don't be
upset if there's like a thousand people
out there because most likely that's
gonna be dude it was from I would go out
like oh my god there's like there's ten
15,000 people already in oh my god
it was insane ever Jimmy I'm nervous
how could Jim so now I could do that
absolutely no well then I would put
together things like this where it was a
sing-along
so with stories stand up sing along game
shows it was an event I think you do
only guy who could pull that off
[ __ ] I log I'm not gonna lie to you
greatest gig ever had my wand you do it
for six months oh my god you two you
were with that from September to March
you weren't the last you weren't home
you were with they tour like
professionals they do 17 18 days
straight every other day okay so we
would let's say we did a concert in
Madison Wisconsin that night we get on
the tour bus yeah they go on their
Learjet and back to wherever they're
based out of Chicago
we then drive through the night to the
next town yeah you get your
you get your key and you go to your room
and you're off all day yeah and then you
don't have to do a show until the
following evening right it was the
greatest gig ever had my I would do this
the rest of my life one of the biggest
bands of lifetime let me see this please
yeah and plus I love them like this is
my good this is my life of him imitating
Metallica and they go to the lead singer
Yas
I sound like yeah I think yeah it's
perfect
listen play this is my favorite like put
instead they would go crazy with this
what is this part I don't know what this
is it's just a single tienda
yeah that's a sing-along so you just
finished up oh I just yeah I ended I
just said it's time for Metallica
because that's so about three seconds
about five seconds before this right
here well this is the beginning so I
said if you don't know the words do they
read them I have the lyrics up the whole
arena he's the only guy who'd do this
Jim and be successful look at the crowd
they're the guys my Dominic
[Music]
how often they do I get goosebumps feel
about it hi here we go what they love
doing that this is a wait right here
and they would go into but the biggest
one was Pantera which I didn't see
coming the pit really not so nuts wow
they must have been so happy with you
being able to do this [ __ ] and then time
to get out there they're like yeah do
the best the best compliment I got was
it was three days before the last day of
the tour the North American tour and
Laura they go Lars wants to see you in
the food room oh okay is he like the
brains the operation he makes a lot of
decisions uh he's he's definitely
probably him and James but Lars is
definitely more active I always say is a
little more active yeah and he's very in
tune and cares a lot about what the fans
think so he's constantly thinking about
that success not before every show they
go in a room and they rehearse for 40
straight minutes playing songs before
they walked out in the arena and play
over two hours how cool is that every
show man every show discipline
discipline complete discipline
discipline yes Hetfield I went why do
you guys why do you guys like wood
Dooney went gym urine Stan we all have
lives because we come here in separate
cars we're not hanging out with you I
got kids I have a family I can I have
this thing everyone's he goes this is
the only time before the show is we shut
the doors we come in the room what are
we playing let's rehearse this and is
the only time we become Metallica team
before we walk out Wow nobody does that
what band does that this band right here
what I'm meeting 40 minutes before I go
I'll be here 40 minutes you can be or
not we're gyms sounding like Metallica
and the guys like I sound like that you
know I'm talking about yeah it was the
icon MTV icons yeah I just saw the other
day man you know the coolest thing MTV
didn't want me they wanted someone else
and Metallica said no we want a roller
right why it obviously was a huge
success I'm surprised Metallica just
doesn't keep doing it with him cuz
they're on tour now there well this was
getting to solarz i go meet with Lars
and he goes he's eating and he goes do
you think this would work say a stadium
atmosphere and I went now and they're
going to Europe and I went different
animal now my ego immediately went you
say yes and you'll figure it out a week
Iowa hi
Eagles say it's daytime
it's Belgium now I you're in the
business I said to be honest with you if
you made me figure it out I could but I
don't it has to be a completely
different show this is different it's an
arena it's indoors I know everyone in
that crowd and if I don't I sort an
American right is there American they
know me if they don't know me they kind
of like is let the guy froude I think I
know I always ask I I would get off the
stage and go up in sections to approach
people like whoa dude he's in the
audience yeah
and so stadiums different animal
different piece
you can't control 80 to 100 just in
their attention on you they're coming to
see me Fiona Apple um I was hanging out
with her and she opened for Coldplay
when they were really huge yeah it was
really interesting cuz she said she'd go
out there and she was you know Fiona
Apple I mean she was great phenomenal
but she's first of all it's the same
thing a lot of people wouldn't be there
but even the people that where was
scattered that was just it was a huge
stadium it would be rolling it wouldn't
catch up you couldn't control it's
impossible because there'd be pockets of
openings yeah and so they would they
would be talking the whole time so she'd
be singing and basically I'd be singing
it be like singing to a giant it could
open like yes Open Mic building a giant
right and in a loud car even even Rogen
said he did
I think Tacoma 25000 he was like just a
different animal man by the time the
word traveled your tags and stuff the
whole the whole rhythm difference I made
for that yeah
to play play this for meet you I just
watch it feeling it oh my god Jimmy the
only guy on the planet can do this have
you seen this B that's Lena price so
excited for it
alright guys look like a baby this was
like 2003 says 3 or Tim just 3 2003 does
Metallica know how good your answer is
it like are you friends already here no
we're friends already weird we're
friends
cuz I guys said they wanted a different
guy and gentle ahead
[Music]
oh my god because I do the constable I'm
sweating so come on tear itself so good
[Music]
is he from sweeteners
he's Denmark he's Danish he still talks
like he does this all the time
this setup is such a long setup so good
Jim oh my god Oh
[Music]
dude this is [ __ ] incredible I'm
telling you sound exactly
I haven't [ __ ] you do this I should jump
America California he was on Rogen
[ __ ] that stop way too long what say you
should I've got B's freeze 70-minute
got caught he got caught up down the
page somebody goes oh you're in de bz as
am i and I was I was so excited I lay on
him and Rogan and then we talk about B's
470 Mythili Wow
have you ever done that though have you
ever gotten found yourself in like a
rabbit hole you're in the middle of the
ocean and you're talking about something
you don't even want to talk about it but
you you're in if you're in you're like
David I gotta find a way out of day
being a copy store last night of
coverage I get off stage so we're
talking about fighting and halfway
through I go oh I don't want to do this
I should go I gotta go
literally keys and mid-conversation go I
gotta go I just dipped out yeah he was
talking about fighting stage no no no I
got off stage also I was asking about a
certain fight and we're he's probably 10
minutes in the store and went oh you're
wasting my time I'm out
I can't ever do that I have to sit there
and listen not me way nice I'm taking I
take deep breath someone move I'm never
employed so I'm gonna sit here with this
person and watch I'm gonna faint
interest and I go like this I go ha
no way man no no you go that's crazy
I can't I've wasted my life forever you
know we do we both do it when we don't
know what's on semi-interesting
oh yeah yeah both do it yeah Sting's a
great word is that's okay really yeah
it's so far that's interesting that's a
good take not like we're you know yeah
that's that's a good I didn't see that
angle that's a good point man we'll have
a good night
that's what's the mills you can just say
something really dumb like you can say
that makes no sense or confuses I'm I'll
go like this I'm so glad I came
yeah I'm so excited I hey man good luck
out there you too yeah yeah but Jim with
that with the Metallica and yeah I saw
you do a ac/dc you did uh that was a
long time ago house a long time a long
time ago
and I did it a field of dreams type of
thing I knew if I would do it eventually
it would get to them and I was hoping
one of them would reach out like ac/dc
yeah and which is what happened ac/dc
reached out yeah
and they loved it I ended up hanging out
with Brian Johnson the singer no let me
see that the sing a song with them and
although he's a bit right huh you did
start off as a bit of really when I
toured when you just show the Metallica
thing back then I was touring with a
band and you sing as that were you I'm a
wannabe yeah but you can say yeah if I
wanted to yes all right but I tried it
it just it's too weird yeah it's just
it's no it takes is there is there is
before you show this is there a singer
is there a frontman you think is
greatest of all time do you have a
favorite band of all time
oh my god there's there's my there's
well is that three no that's the way
answer now right here's my here's my bed
ac/dc metallica but I love the Beatles
and if but jim breuer world was Judas
Priest
okay you Metallica ac/dc yeah that was
my that is my nucleus and then you know
I like I like staying learning I like
the hot little journey one or two one or
two songs you know get up at the
ballpark
Wow I love just seventh-inning I get up
Billy Joel alright play this for me too
I get to nice shirt
this is on your comedy central's 30
minute special this was my first hour
special touch Oh Oh Judas Priest yeah
damn no one knew who you was this is you
hi here dimmer now um just wondering
what extent I don't need you what I
don't think so too much energy now or
not for this one you don't look like it
no no no mmm this is yesterday oh yeah
yeah the kids how much you sound like a
dill it's so crazy how much you sound
like oh my [ __ ] god
I mean it's identical if he keeps going
that's all I do is mimic but it mimics
what I see is so elaborate the stories
it's really look well I won't be doing
this how I do I'll tell you that I've
never seen this [ __ ] dude this is so
good look at you you're ad you're
actually very athletic
I used it you know what I gotta say
Brian you know the song that I love is
my way by Sinatra uh-huh I it's hurt me
yes that but at the same time it's it's
a my entire career whatever it's so I've
always did what I wanted to do yeah and
now there were times I should be doing
this so I should be doing that
always done exactly what I want to do
and and the key to me and I before the
podcast started so you talking to your
daughter the balance of life really is
having your home life and so it's great
this is a phenomenal world to chase but
I wanted to have that at what expense
and to have my family in the home and
getting home my dad to his last breath
and have my mom in might and all
experiences in life I can honestly say
I've I've I [ __ ] him Forrest Gump yeah I
feel great I guess sing with Brian
Johnson I get to had a great or
Metallica I got to work with Tom Hanks I
got to De Niro Pesci I get to sing on
stage with Billy Joel and I'm glad
you're saying this because this is what
I think you should tell them Jim's gonna
die in three weeks
but you're right dude and it's funny
because where's great careers you had I
watch all this and you've had these
incredible moments they they are not
anchoring the you'll always be a comic
so you'll have a place to go on a home
but it's not an ultimate home it's not
it's not the ultimate anchor without
friends and family and that anchor but
I'll say this Jim oh I don't know
feelings obviously I'm a huge fan that
you've read this stuff when they said
you're coming on with oh he's one of the
greats
what a way people view you brother well
well thank you take your shirt off and
that's not Mike I'm not you're not like
a leash comic or you know now you know
that means a lot to me more than you
know that's what you sell when the
founder tickets every fun what more than
you know it means more because as time
goes on it's never was the a-lister type
guy or anything in that world you didn't
feel that way I'm telling you from from
where I come from my friends and my
circle you're as ælis of the gift well
thank you yeah I think you need be
reminded of that all right
that's why I'm saying it I need to
remind myself I'm gonna man I'm gonna
tell my wife always be something don't
call my wife after this right let me
talk you understands going on
and call my wife you know that my kids
know what time it is always on the road
though if you have if you have kids
there's a bit of like it like there's a
resentment like I'm just like man I'm
missing stuff or like yeah you know Mike
I yeah I got another kid come in
November I am whoa I have three you know
three three dates in November there's a
good chance hope I don't miss the birth
that's special that you were just
watching yeah my daughter was born late
and I had crazy
they're called cluster headaches which
worse than migraines because this
special was filmed February 2nd I think
and she was due January 21st D and if
you watched that if you go back and look
at that I came straight from the
hospital and look at my I believe my
left hand still has some I dot my second
daughter was just born take that off
I think I forgot I might have forgot but
they're really cool too or to me they're
really cool yeah so that's I'll always
remember my second daughter was just
born a day or two before the special and
it absolutely stress without you know
was that it's a I don't know somewhere
in New York yeah I think I think it's
tough with comics or anyone
entertainment because you gotta make a
living life for your family but it takes
away yeah from being we're also not
there a lot of times like I always say
this to people in my family everybody I
had to solve these problems like I have
to come up with a new hour or I got a
call with new jokes and that's how I
make my living and there are a lot of
problems to solve in my head as far as
comedy so I'm not always gonna be that
present it's also hard to be present
it's hard to be in Seattle have that
plum I can shut it down when I when I
get home yeah I can shoot when I'm there
I don't have my phone I can shut it down
and get on the ground and do my thing
with him and then I can turn it on awful
yeah yeah it's good do
do you feel where you're at you have to
what is your outlet you filming one-hour
special what's your next like you you
got to get a special and you want to get
it on this network that networks
well now it's like where's would you put
this specially if you do it here is
people gonna see it do you do do it over
here because everyone the if you do they
Andrew Schultz thing where you're
releasing clips here and there and you
put it on YouTube so because what's the
goal of a specialties to get more people
than what is the goal want to sell
tickets to sell tickets for the next so
to sell tickets we're gonna sell the
most tickets put it behind a paywall on
showtime or HBO or put it on Netflix
don't forget the right algorithm or
release it on youtube if you get it on
the right if it's you forgot see and
you're really funny and enough people
see it on Netflix it changes your whole
life but it's true that the business
model is changing where us was it Jim
well I I've discovered the social media
world I'm starting to use that as my
weapon because because I've been doing
all different shows my biggest
frustration was yes I thrive to make
that one hour but and I find myself
creating a new one pretty quickly when
when did you tape your last 1 hour
I was this mm was well at least four
years ago five years ago would you do it
with epics and and hear that this was
something frustrating where nobody
watches well no epics had to deal with
Netflix so my first special I did with
epics and they were really good to me
when on Netflix and he did tremendous it
was called and laughter for all hence
the Metallica little thing only people
in the metalic 100 and justice for all
oh okay and let the fro so I did that
and they did great started selling
tickets then it did so good I was ready
for my next one the very following year
I filmed it epics did it and right
before
went out Epic's had a fallout with
Netflix so not only is it's not gonna
pulled my own special off because it was
epics so what's a Netflix and Wyatt why
why am I being punished why so then I
had another one and couldn't you went to
epic I'm like dude let Netflix keep this
well was under them and it didn't matter
it whatever happened between them it
doesn't matter so what you're left with
is well now what do you do so what do I
do now okay you know what I always have
new material and are we in the day and
age where you have to do one hour on
tour and one hour to know so the Angela
Schultz method and my method is I have
so much different material I film every
single show now and I record every
single put on your social media and I
put clips here and social media in
social media and what I'm excited about
is from the Paramount I can honestly say
I think I have at least three new
one-hour specials one was just done st.
Patrick's Day where I came out would it
kill Dublin I went thank god we've
filmed that one was after this Billy
Joel thing where I got I I brought my
daughter she wanted to see Billy Joel in
concert I went there I have two martinis
in my system and before I know is that
you want to meet Billy Joel oh my god oh
my god yeah now we meet Billy Joel do
zared you do ac/dc
yeah you know I imitate you ask oh I'm
doomed tonight Wyatt with Wyatt
what do you type next thing you know I'm
singing Billy Joel and he's easy song
and then I came on say and I talked
about it just as pump there's another
special so it's I think the social media
world now I can control when I'm
releasing this there it is right there
yeah this is why is freaked out
oh my god I realize that you were they
like holy [ __ ] that's pretty cool well
how am I allowed to you let me tell you
the back story of this first of all my
daughter wants to go see Billy Joel
phenomenal how old's your daughters she
was 16
okay so I was
Jahna static then I'm not listening to
angry rap cursing she wants to lose ears
because that's all I hear down there I'm
down the hallway yeah they're getting
crunk and I went Billy Joel she was a
legend okay so I call my age hey man
could give me three tickets for Billy
Joel it's a 50-year anniversary who
knows who's gonna show up maybe Bono
maybe a Springsteen somebody showing up
for the 50th anniversary I show up I've
two martinis my wife and daughter meet
me hey you want to meet Billy Joel next
thing he goes hey man you want you want
to go out to ac/dc
I froze this is the last thing I
expected and I went I I don't think I'll
remember the lyrics it's what I said and
he looked at he looked at his manager
and he goes because you know we should
have had you here early goes tell you
what line should come back another time
you hang out with the band you learn the
song you know the lyrics and then we'll
rehearse and you do another time is that
cool you know I yeah so now we go in
another room and the show that I used to
but when I used to have on satellite you
would come in all the time Billy Joel's
guitar issues to come in all the time he
comes sees me inside the room because
Breuer you do ac/dc tonight or what
I told Billy you could knock this out or
Tommy I I'm not gonna remember the
lyrics because there's there's monitors
all over the stage Jim I usually look at
they're huge
they're all over the place with big
lyrics he goes if you get lost on stage
you can go right to Billy's piano right
there sing me a song
piano man England this big the lyrics
you're not gonna forget the lyrics I
wanna draw you don't want to come
because you know you have to do it
because you don't get for the 54 of the
58th because you do it tonight
Oh ability listen Tom he said we should
rehearse which I agree you would fall he
leaves he comes back who's Jeb Bush good
he calls a guy charlie
Brewers gonna come out a tenth one find
out where they're sitting and I like
Tommy we got to go
are we gonna go to you're gonna kill it
now you can't draw the [ __ ] cops
exactly and SOGs and you're thinking in
your head I gotta [ __ ] do this
ah that's exactly what's going on of
course it's so now I'm sitting there
like this
now I'm sang this song a million times
at weddings or with my friend I'm sorry
Joe
not at 50 here what's up so I that's
like being screwed no clothes on exactly
this is a design so you know exactly
where I'm at so I'm nervous I'm sitting
there in the crowd like this and I
forgot oh my god was videotaped I went
holy [ __ ] oh so I'm going all right she
was a fast machine she can't remember
the lyrics she said I can't get past the
first verse it was fascinating kept the
motor clean best end would [ __ ] shed
somewhere the thighs or sighs and I'm
going oh my daughter's I got a big yeah
[Music]
I'm outside the bathroom for 20 minutes
like trying to learn I'm gonna [ __ ] this
up now I'm gone what if what what if
there's an old guy doing the lyrics and
he's too slow
what if the monitor is just going too
[ __ ] slow hey your daddy and they
they all have earpieces what if I can't
hear the band I don't know what it
sounds like up there what this is
[ __ ] does that and before I can even
think the guy comes I guess Brewer time
to go oh [ __ ] it's like a walking behind
a stage and I'm watching him do New York
state of mind
thank God people in New York State
crying they're crying the great songs
and I'm Sydney and now here's nothing
when I'm nervous
don't talk to me breathe I'm like a dick
when I'm nervous I mean a mean yeah so
the stage manager
he knows arrow knows I'm a Mets fan so
goes bro do you think about this new
Mets Maj Mickey Callaway's it is your
guy trying to see when he's bringing me
up he though you know I mean his trade I
mean I get Todd Frazier he's a good
third baseman but you got a guy like
Moustakas and he goes are you nurse wear
yet are you nervous
you call you nervous I'm like yeah yes
oh dude Miley Cyrus is here she was
nervous I was asking why you nervous she
said I'm singing with a legend shot
[ __ ] nervous so now he goes surprised
they can give you cookies when am i
going out there goes all you'll know all
son you'll know so before us is good you
have to know the lead-up to this moment
cuz people people look at this and I
think all Jim and Billy Joe are best
friends Jesus madam for 36 so he goes
this is what he says I'll never forget
it so I'm sitting there my heart's going
a million miles an octave and he goes so
uh I have a special guest and no place
goes apeshit and that's what I realize
20,000 phones are in the air huh oh my
this moment yeah because I guess I swear
to god he's setting me up for disaster
he goes he looks as guitar playing is
this is a really difficult song to sing
it's just like that we try this is a
tough song because he's not known as a
singer he's totally setting up this is
gonna this is it
and if he goes and then he goes you he's
fixing his he's fix his nails yes you
may know him as the gold boy and I'm
gonna back on that's why I'm coming they
were waiting for Mick Jagger hey [ __ ] me
Jagger we got go to go
we got better go boy he did the thing on
YouTube so he goes please Jim Breuer
right welcome to Brewer I come walking
out I had a whole speech
my my I was gonna say I want to thank
Billy grew up on Long Island I'm gonna
audience a so my daughter's 16th
birthday out of all the world she want
to see Billy Joel that's gonna get a big
my wife but married 26 years she's a
what's up Billy Joel a [ __ ] went after
window I come [ __ ] you same guy he's got
a guitar and he makes a left so I okay
okay but commit the drums it sad women
jumped out of their seats and they
rushed the stage of dance I now here's
the best part right so I I became around
like a lot heavy camera rockstar yeah I
squatted down right when you watch I
squat down like a frontman because I
know where the frontman looks like and
I'm pointing at these two shits there's
70 and over but doesn't matter
hopped up on valium they're appreciative
grateful pleasure
right they're grateful right great
they're grateful but here's the funniest
part you had the a days I crush it but
what I'm really doing I'm just reading
the monitors [ __ ] oh could you
see you watch me watch this right when
you watch me I'm constantly looking down
is it the second one this you got a
figure 20 looking down what do you think
it is Jen the second minute the second
ones more than once I've got a second
one yeah yeah I could the one there it
says you shook me all night long
this one yeah is it I know this is it
all right all right he just brings me
out okay
hey how you doing bill thank God I had a
leather jacket on thank God smiley Billy
Joe is the [ __ ] look at how great he
is
I'm not sure to do I'm looking I'm
looking for the monitor I'm looking for
the money I just found it okay now I go
to Harvard watch my eyes see Emily Hey
look now I squat down cuz I'm having a
hard time reading it but if you look at
my eyes yeah I keep looking at the mats
all I'm doing yeah but it looks like
you're playing the viola it looks like
I'm playing feels like lose your whole
front Rambla you know what you're
expected to sing and you can't be bad
that can't be bad had a comedian you
can't be bad here and I'm not gonna lie
to you when it was over I felt so high
of adrenaline that dude as I was walking
on you sound like the crowd those crabs
loving it sort of you know I
you know I love jokes and everybody is I
like the diversity they're all my age
and older it's not a white people always
it's not makjang herbut okay so the best
part is when I was over dude you're
pulling it off though I'm starting to
run out of gas and run out of breath
[Music]
keep ground the dick though it's a good
mind grab the dick it's all around
lightly all can't lose your voice see
the problem with this is that there you
can't go out there and be shitty you
have to you but this is a concert you
gotta crush this it's good lovin it
there they had a great time when it was
over until the show plays guitar swear
to God
there's a small part ooh me want to go
right on the monitor be like you guys
one you you pull it off but that's the
guy that got right there he's so proud
and happy at the black shirt behind me
he's like you just say I ask you they
that put you in a real position if you
have a fascist that song did practice
parts on the zone but I did I can use
only I could pull it off oh my god I
knew you could really Josey knows
[ __ ] dope yeah they're not gonna
bring you out if they've never seen that
was karaoke with a live band that's what
that was with and that could've
absolutely sound oh it could have gone
south because because what happens is in
about three minutes if you start losing
your voice we have nowhere to go and
there's no humor there you're kind of
depressed all right bad song I'm moving
on yeah is that good we didn't know how
I was gonna go clearly didn't go the way
happy 50th yeah yeah we do Billy Joel's
50th show Harry Connick jr. one time in
San Diego five I don't know 10,000
people he goes Brian come on up here and
say some words he's real funny lady and
gentlemen he's a funny guy now they
crowd you this dude nobody knew me
nobody knew me I've done MADtv twice for
two years I'm up there and I'm like I'm
on a date
all right guys I said something like
where's the to but we need a tube up
here I get some jokes yeah I couldn't he
go say some [ __ ] Brian make us laugh and
then I go well you're on the stage he
jumps into the audience and says my girl
now I'm alone and I go feelings nothing
more than nothing for that bro
it didn't work dude it did work and I
sang a little bit of feelings and that's
all I do I go listen I'd like to do this
more but I gotta get out of here
bye you know what the worst is oh where
the circus sounds like that I bet you
left and then you went if I had known I
would have done X Y Z well you put in
the worst circumstances hamper I'm on a
first date because the first thing I
would've thought of was just the first
day Thursday either go on a character I
don't I don't even live here
with this girl and you can't just start
doing
Stano especially it's and it's it's it's
mixed baby-making music man they're not
there this yeah oh sure now there's some
guy nobody knows by the way some guy
nobody knows Brian say a couple words no
aha
Harry kind of spongy man where's the
tube but in his mind he thought it was
gonna be he didn't mean it like yeah not
he thinks he knows before 9:00 is
turning on oh my god yeah baby sometimes
maybe you ever had something go bad like
that Jim oh god yeah you have to
improvise you can't do material but not
not a years ago yeah horrible bombs in
front of the house what happened there
was to you you brought up we were just
talking off before the podcast yeah you
brought up David tell ya I got a David
tell horrendous bombing story for me and
I have a story of uh playing some big
radio thing was like 15,000 people and I
ate it so hard so hard but the worst was
the worst it's not really I couldn't on
a spot it's just eating it hard
in front of people just bombing
horrendously this thing called Gator
growl they're heard yes sir it's it's
the Gators the Florida Gators Jackson
gained closest nose at Gainesville can't
feel don't say Jack they amp this they
start they start showing up a week
before in campers and all that FSU game
or something
I have no big game oh no it's playing
okay it's in the football stadium and
before they do it
it's it's like seventy eighty thousand
people okay that's easy to control now
you're listening to swamp you know they
go loosen uh you know the bid the
greatest of grades have been here I'm
Billy Crystal do whatever they said if
you uh it was Daniel Tosh how to go
first no new dan has a baby
all Florida and Dave Attell I had to do
fifteen minutes I had to go up and
finish it I think at 25 or a half-hour
so you were the you're the head make
sure we go got touch point I what day
was telling you Dustin Daniel Tosh a
baby you know I'm looking at man it and
you're three tears up the stage is like
off level two okay and in between is
bands like man marching bands and
cheerleaders and there's videos and
people speaker alway burner under skulle
vara so they said if you curse now this
is the biggest paycheck I've ever had my
life that big for that one for a gig and
I gotta say even to this day one of the
biggest paychecks Wow and I went oh my
god I'm in someone crapped out of it and
they said we want you to fill it in so
oh my god so I'm thinking after
tonight's gig I'm gonna make I'm gonna
be making at least this paycheck and
then some homie plane stayed this is
gonna be a monster event for me so I'm
there to get that check and crush it if
you curse if you smoke if you making fun
of homosexuals bring up religion yep
your check is gone no problem sign right
here no problem now I'm thinking how is
it tale gonna
hold this off huh how is he gonna pull
off
he can't curse he can't he can't talk
about religion he can't talk about say
this is easy I gotta watch this even
Daniel - man he's a dirty I don't
remember what Daniella tell though would
a tell would say things like to have
children ma'am no well then you're a
failure I mean he's all I got
I'll tell you what happen can't wait for
this is before insomnia and everything
so and I actually learned from Dave on
this one so Tosh goes up no one's known
even pay attention him they don't know
who he is and he's a young kid and all
of a sudden Patel goes on stage and I
watched him sign the contract was scary
great he lights a cigarette on the stage
and record what the hell what the hell
son Joey yes let's get this out of the
way
lesbian almost sexual [ __ ] he goes on
and on and on what's a need answered him
going sorry Dean tonight's for the
students sometimes I stick my [ __ ] in
the fish ball just to let him know who's
boss wah wah
I love this time of year is it Mears
eggnog just Elcom they're rioting
there's rioting I just went oh my god
he's a genius
dirty walks on stage he walks by because
guess I'm not getting paid money beasts
oh wow I just what a legend
it started with section 147 section
turd I ended doing [ __ ] hand it was
bad I did if you pay for I gotta check
the following David tell like there's a
gangster movie I see what I needed my
first biggest gig was doing this for us
see what they had there there yes right
huge so so they they go look you have
screens it look great who's this word
this for us see so so use of the hair
hold what Pete Carroll came out he had
the team so I have to come out and do Oh
30 minutes of clean Matoo I look out
there though and the there's there's a
guard there's a guard gate card and so
the nearest student is I don't know
forever yeah eight the 50-yard line
yeah I mean 20 yards away 30 so I go
this is not good it's outdoors and it's
crazy and I go how are they gonna listen
to me and they're introducing the
football players and it's the big thing
and it's the entire campus so I go I'm
not Dave Attell ladies and gentlemen I
can't do those things no man I wish I
could but I'm I don't know what I'm
doing so I get out and I do a nice and I
and I know I know it's gonna be a
[ __ ] disaster right now and I go I'm
gonna eat the biggest dick I'm gonna
stick this eye camera I think I was
going I want a pet eagle I had some
psycho maybe I'll start with having a
pet eagle that I can stick up he's great
job brah I want to just you know what
not funny not Dave Attell and I go into
my might and I remember one guy's going
like this try to encourage me that way
in the 25 yard line
and they're going it's already started
where are the sections they made a
[ __ ] mister I'm getting paid I'm at
the time I think it was making it was
more than I ever made and then I had 20
grand was like a lot dude this was more
oh I'm sure he'll squash or was gym but
for me I was nobody I was a [ __ ]
I'm getting 20 grand I was a lot of
money for me right I wasn't just a lot
of money it was for a half-hour period
and I USC yeah so I'm like oh I can't
wait I got to make this right and and by
the way he's going through all the other
comedians that have done it the big
comedian right
well I've arrived so I'm not
exaggerating I was I was three minutes
into my bit they [ __ ] something up in
the middle of my act the audio the
marching band come get me in a puzzled
way I've been doing as long as no one
I'm gonna eat a dick yeah I go then I
get this is gonna be a disaster
here goes it comes on stage I got 20
grand for three minutes of work see you
later and the woman goes come on we
don't know why go they go well that's it
I guess we're sorry we're so sorry
minutes will happen now how about at the
time at the Tim Tebow charity oh that's
so so not good
so there were sick kids in the audience
so let me fill you in on this Jim so I
would do this Tim Tebow charity every
year Tim's a good friend of mine and
they go hey man we need to have a
comedian up here we always like to open
this thing with the fundraiser with a
comic and they originally they asked me
to do I can't do clean comedy I've been
doing it that long
you need you I got the guy free I get
Bryan Callen they go really go he's
amazing he's made great there okay cool
set up all our flights go down there
before Brian hits the stage that his
brother who runs all that goes so this
is how we're gonna do it so they're
super religious egos so we're gonna say
prayer don't wanna be Bryant we're gonna
bring Brian up and I went hey no a
prayer ready I'm gonna crush it it's all
athletes no problem and then I go and
then they go hey man make sure he keeps
it super clean everyone in the
description oh we didn't know this
no they gym there's make-a-wish kids in
the back who will die in seven weeks
yeah I'm not I'm not doing it all
all right here I go I can't do this I'm
gonna talk about jerking off standing up
I can't well I just done hey Brian get
so super Brian gets up and goes does
somebody for your exact bit does it
Vegas let's be honest no I am funnier
than Jesus Christ
oh oh I'm funnier than goes like this oh
oh man we're doing it I mean you know
that they wouldn't their blubber ball
great men like Einstein you know Sam I
agree funnier that I mean I'm funnier
than the gray pause Michael I mean even
Jesus I don't think he could follow me
he could heal people and he usually it
would kill cuz I the way I know it's
funny tbonz looking at me like this oh
they go from him to me I'm like this oh
oh oh okay Brian
oh by the way and I have a happy 11 year
old with the oxygen right here I can't
do comedy I can't do my dirty [ __ ] well
I'm talking about Batman jerking off hot
all over his computer I can't do any of
this I ate the biggest dick I hate the
big I was like yo Urban Meyer the only
one laughing his ass off
Urban Meyer even he kind of man he Bruin
kind of kick did the tough flight it was
that good Jim thanks for having me here
this is an honor they took it out on me
well they asked me to apologize and I
was like I can't do that but yeah it was
it was what it was it was fine wow wow
yeah you know it's a part of our lives
happens man [ __ ] happens part of her I
know a lot of people like that it was uh
Jamie Foxx I think was talking about
doing something with De Niro and all
these people in the room I think was
Jamie or someone and just ate a dick
because it was a bank they were eating
dinner and thank what Sammy starts
trying to wrote every one of the row
stuff it's Jamie Foxx and everybody's
like do you do corporate events yeah I
did a private event
about three months ago and it was a huge
music guy that owned this huge music
company that was retiring
and I show up my god and it was 12
people and it was a room a little bigger
than this and they were sitting in two
round tables and I had a just stand
there there's no microphone it like yell
from a soapbox
it was the most mortifying awkward and I
would try to talk to the guy it's not
ending it was you feel like a [ __ ]
are you taking the check I have a buddy
good friend of ours don't say his name
but a big-time celebrities that came out
what you do 15 minutes of stand-up at my
wedding
outside no he's like no man that's not
me to be a terrible you may not be good
you may be I'm not and if it was funny
yeah but you've never done actually 50
minutes of stand-up and it's not the
something there's some there's some
comics who are beasts at the corporate
gig so it's just summer and I feel it I
know Aziz I won't say who he went with a
friend of mine it's company that brought
in Aziz and then I came in he can't say
this this and this
he was like yeah cool went up there and
just kind of did his thing
they didn't go well he's like give me my
check I'm [ __ ] out of it just go
that's the thing you gotta realize it's
just a you know this is gonna pay for
the kids going to college this is gonna
help with this gigs anymore I don't want
I remember that last when he did he sent
me a video yeah I'm not doing that [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] ended there were lawyers
and they got offended Ben did she came
up and scolded me in anything that yeah
and I was like I thought that I'd be
remit you could definitely mo ver
remember I got offered that corporate
gig in Jacksonville I called you I'm
telling you do not do it now I don't you
look at them I feel like I'm I feel like
I'm being a [ __ ] it is and I'm not
doing it you're not so I will never ever
do stand-up where you tell me I can't
say certain things
go [ __ ] yourself here's my show right
here's myself go [ __ ] yourself know what
you're in the answer the new you again
doing it for money I do those I don't do
things for money that way hence the Dave
Attell yeah I learn driving that my god
yes I'm not getting paid what a legend
man
is did he get paid he probably did I
don't think you did I doubt it God I did
but they don't play that game
ah Johar social me if people want to
find your tour tickets we're gonna keep
you all I don't know Instagram Facebook
that I'm bigger on Facebook is it
working at Jim Breuer yeah
live right live that's my facebook at
you even let laughs live and let laughs
that's the term what is in terms this
ego see Jim Breuer obviously because
he's one of the greats Jim or whatever
never not been painfully funny Jim
Breuer dunya man I love it though I love
to comedy you're amazing Breuer your
poems or underscore official yeah Jim
just start doing um well you have your
first page that's you might have enough
followers look at me right now start
doing funny [ __ ] on your Instagram I
just started doing it I just started
Larry's like just you know my dad over
there but the videos amazing what the
videos are starting to do like just
marrying attention well do like I told
you ones are great you're the best man
you're really thanks man and man thanks
for your kind words yes I think you need
to hear that man I love the more I hear
at the better yeah appreciate ya I was
honored that I was able to come here
yeah we love you man we're gonna do a
little we do a section in the show where
we do a little light wrestling right
here okay Bryan's gonna take your shirt
off we keep our oil nope shirts off
light oils off I'll be the referee and
then chin will video it you'll have to
bite yeah in a Christian way Jim Breuer
ladies and gentlemen kid pure so you
were matching money she'll get more it's
all good Kim pure hey Jim you were
thanks so much for coming that shyness
Nolan
viewer or a now-or-never this is the
fighter and the kid we're out